benjamin cube journaliste auteur le
livre noir de renault aux éditions first
bonsoir benjamin cucq merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors du
parti communiste aux arènes en passant
par l'est républicain les oppositions
demandé aujourd'hui à l'état de se faire
respecter
si renault devait confirmer ces
fermeture de quatre sites en france
c'est pas à l'ordre du jour pour le
moment condamnation unanime votre
réaction à vous c'est une condamnation
de gens qui ont été au pouvoir pendant
des années et qui ont organisé eux-mêmes
des délocalisations et c'est assez
amusant d'entendre le parti communiste
français qui est don avec ses amis de la
cgt qui a une seule ya une semaine a
refusé à faire en sorte de ne pas
reprendre le travail
sandouville je vais à un moment il faut
comme ça on peut s'inquiéter du de la
désindustrialisation par le manque de
volonté politique de certains politiques
de gauche comme de droite et de la
destruction de l'industrie automobile
par cette non volonté politique et qui
maintenant maintenant je pousse des cris
d'orfraie alors que ce n'est que la
cause succession de l'heure de leur
politique est elle pour vous il ya une
forme des banques réside aujourd'hui
dans ses réactions
cc c'est plus que d'hypocrisie ainsi
quasiment de la tartufferie quand on
sait quand on sait que certains
politiques certains partis politiques
ont été au pouvoir pendant quelques
dizaines d'années ont nommé des gens à
la tête de renault
des gens qui bossait à l'elysée par
exemple on derrière on se peut
s'interroger sur la réalité de la
politique du ps oui par exemple ou même
de délocalisation de la gare de madame
lagarde était ministre de l'économie
quand renault était à délocaliser la
toux la clio en turquie
le ps était au pouvoir quand renault a
déclaré mme délocaliser la twingo en
slovénie
on peut s'interroger sur les
conséquences de ces gens ces gens sont
des gens ces personnels politiques ont
des actions inconséquente et viennent se
plaindre des années après de renchérir
le gouvernement sera intransigeant sur
la préservation des sites en france
c'était de voir philippins qui le dit
aujourd'hui quelle est votre réaction
justement face à ce cette fermeté
affichée
ben je souhaite que le premier ministre
soit différent de ses prédécesseurs ne
serait ce que pour les l'intérêt
industriel de la france
il en veut il emmène la très officielle
de la france on a vu il ya peu de temps
la semaine dernière les effets de sanofi
qui annonce que le vaccin serait
disponible d'abord pour les américains
les français sanofi ses nombreux fans
ski français serait dommage que renault
ne soit qu'une entreprise française
demain et donc c'est à l'état aussi
d'être protecteur 6 2 s'il veut être
s'il veut montrer qu'il est qu'il est
fort et qu'il est et maintenir l'emploi
en france en tant qu'actionnaire mais
l'emploi de tout de tout temps le
gouvernement français c'est qu'on s'est
comporté en en fonds de pension c'est à
dire qu'il a attendu des dividendes de
renault il a attendu des dividendes de
renault et ils cherchent encore une fois
maintenir les évidentes parce que cette
année pour la première fois renault
était déficitaire depuis bien longtemps
alors le gouvernement en tout cas
prévoit les non ce sont quinze jours dit
il d'un plan de soutien à l'automobile
c'est de nature à vous rassurer
oui c'est moins sûr mais c'est ça
profite à tous les constructeurs
heureusement nez on vit dans un monde en
une dans un pays libre de marché et il
savait que le mail que le meilleur gagne
moi j'ai eu des renault pendant des
années j'aime beaucoup cette marque
cironneau m'offre nous propose fait une
offre commerciale intéressante je dirais
avec je vois l'intérêt mais je verrai
aussi en fonction de lieu de production
c'est bien géré les c'est sympa c'est
sympa de faire est d'acheter des
voitures fabriquées à l'autre bout du
monde
mais si c'est fabriqué
c'est fabriqué par des employés la bac
sont des chômeurs en france et à l'est
par des chômeurs en france sans merci
aux défendre son industrie enfin une
forme de patrimonio patriotisme
patrimoniale et industriels je suis je
suis libéral je suis d'essence libérale
alors justement c'est un mot le
patriotisme en ce moment après cette
crise du duc ovide 19 ans parle de de
rockwell relocaliser les industries en
france ça concerne certainement
l'automobile aussi un vous y croyez ou
c'est pas gagné quand même hein le
problème c'est qu'il ya un coût du
travail en france qui est très élevé si
vous produisez en france vous renchérit
c'est 10% si vous produisez toutes les
roms en france renchérit laisser 10% le
prix d'une renault elle devient plus
compétitif par rapport au reste c'est à
dire que nous renault qui vous nouveau
sur un sur un et dix ans la renault sera
110 donc le marché fera qu on ira plutôt
sur une autre voiture et en même temps
on peut acheter une toyota qui est
fabriqué en france confort des usines en
france des usines de moteurs et des
usines qui emploient des frontaliers à
sarrelouis ans à sarrebruck en allemagne
bond à sare on peut il ya d'autres
constructeurs
on peut on peut fabriquer les voitures
étrangères en france ce n'est pas un
problème et on peut fabriquer des
voitures françaises dans l'union
européenne c'est pas un problème tout
simplement a totalement vide et c'est le
jure f2c de cbc
politiciens qui rêvaient d'une entrevue
d'une france sans usines
c'est un vieux rêve de l'est de l'ère
mitterrand ça c'est la france sans
usines
il faudrait une france qui n'a plus
d'usinés voilà moi je suis pas
miterrandiste donc ça me pose pas le
problème de penser que c'est bien qu'ils
aient des usines en france
merci beaucoup vagin m'accuse d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
journalistes auteurs du livre noir de
renault merci à vous